what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really
interesting news about Agatha coven of
chaos it looks like Selena Gomez could
be joining the MCU now Selena Gomez is
extremely popular one of the most
popular superstars on the planet and
she's actually been with Disney for a
pretty long time she pretty much became
known for her role in Disney's Wizards
of Waverly Place so she's had a
connection with Disney for a pretty long
time so if people wanted to meet with
her about joining the MCU it wouldn't be
that hard to set up and keep in mind
Marvel Studios and Disney have been
getting some really big named actors for
a lot of their films recently and Selena
Gomez is definitely a big name now for
these new rumors about Selena Gomez
joining the MCU and Agatha Covenant of
chaos the rumors just say that she could
have already been cast for a role they
do not specify the role however there
are some rumors of some other actors
that have been cast for this as well
that kind of help us narrow down a
certain role that she could be playing
and it looks like she might actually be
playing another witch now most of the
accounts that I've seen online have just
said that this report is coming from an
Insider but don't specify who so take
this as just a rumor for now but it's
posted on many different accounts like
MCU content and the rumor is that she'll
make a cameo it doesn't necessarily say
that she's going to play a big role but
a cameo well we sort of know what Agatha
coven of chaos is going to be about just
think about the name Kevin of chaos so
it's probably going to be about her
coven either the old one and or her new
one in one division we saw a little bit
of her old coven unfortunately but
fortunately for her she killed them all
the coven of witches that she used to
belong to she killed so we definitely
could be and probably are going to
explore some of her backstory a little
bit more in Coven of chaos but also talk
about where she is now because the last
time we left her Wanda had put her back
under a spell and pretty much locked her
inside of her her own mind and West View
now based off what some people have said
and based off of common sense as well we
know that one of the episodes most
likely the first one is going to be
about her kind of breaking out of the
spell that Wanda put her under and then
breaking out of West View and then her
going back to wherever she originally
came from before hunting Wanda down in
Westview which we right now don't have
any idea about so perhaps when she goes
back we could be introduced to New Salem
originally Agatha Harkness was from
Salem Massachusetts and was prosecuted
during the Salem Witch Trials where she
was accused by her own coven of being a
witch which of course she was she is but
New Salem was actually in Colorado and
this was actually a magical Community
where you could practice magic openly
and not be afraid of anybody trying to
kill you and this is where I think we
might meet Selena Gomez Selena Gomez
could possibly be a witch in New Salem
an acquaintance or friend Vaga the
Harkness because keep this in mind in
the comics Agatha Harkness isn't
actually bad she's not the best good
person superhero out there but she does
help the Fantastic Four specifically
Reed Richards and Sue storm and she is
the nanny of Franklin Richards who goes
on to become one of the most powerful
mutants possibly the most powerful
mutant in all of Marvel history we're
talking about a kid who can create
universes just with his own powers
create universes and at one point in
time even resurrected Galactus from the
dead and then used Galactus basically as
a puppet Galactus was actually serving
him so I'm assuming we're going to get a
lot of backstory about where Agatha's
from and this is where I think Selena
Gomez is going to come into play now
again the rumor just says Cameo and
we've had plenty of really famous actors
come in and do just cameos in either a
show or a movie think of Matt Damon in
Thor love and thunder and then again in
Thor Ragnarok however I personally think
that a big name like Selena Gomez might
not be there for just a cameo and
perhaps could even have a future in the
MCU however of course she's one of the
biggest celebrities in the world right
now and her schedule is probably really
busy but if she's a Marvel fan and wants
to do just a cameo that would be really
awesome as well but again this is just a
rumor for now but let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below would you like to see her in the
MCU do you think she would make a good
witch or do you think she'll play a
different character in Agatha Kevin of
chaos let us know your thoughts Down
Below in the comments don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on all the latest MCU news for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof